aujourd'hui face à vous toute l'équipe
de la chasse aux trésors cette émission
qui passe le dimanche après midi vers 18
heures sur antenne 2 en tête de cette
équipe le producteur jacques antoine
j'avoue est déjà venu nous expliquer
comment se passer cette émission comment
vous l'aviez imaginé comment voulez vous
réalisiez bien maintenant j'aimerais que
vous nous présentiez vos principaux
collaborateurs car comme toujours il en
manque quelques-uns oui bien sûr le oui
oui ils manquent eux mêmes un des
collaborateurs essentiel c'est le
cameramen ou parce que vous verrez je
pense que les téléspectateurs filmés
alors ils mentent pas vrai noir là il
sera élevé rendant au courant des vues
au cours de l'émission que il joue un
rôle très important s'appelle jean yves
le maner alors mais a bien entendu il ya
philippe gildas philippe de dieuleveult
de philippe j'avoue que c'est un peu
compliqué surtout pour des gens qui
doivent se parler au téléphone
alors à vous de philippe louis philippe
sétois philips oui je suis moi aussi j
-c phillips et philippe tout on n'a pas
osé les débaptisés ensuite il y à jean
luc noël qui est un acide assistant qui
possède repérage à ça tout à l'heure
ainsi que rené denis les réalisateurs
jean jacques pasquet et claude savarit
bien alors philippe gildas d'être le
premier à qui je posais un certain
nombre de questions parce que vous êtes
celui qui qui qui fait se poser le plus
de questions aux téléspectateurs on se
demande d'abord pour quelles raisons
vous êtes sans arrêt en train de
discuter de chercher à vos papiers sans
jamais regarder de téléviseurs je vous
connais la réponse devrait quand même
une fois de plus que vous le disiez
c'est la section le téléviseur une voie
que moi même où les concurrents dix ans
avec moi mon n'a pas l'image nous sommes
les seuls à ne pas avoir l'image au fond
est ce que vous croyez qu'on pourrait
dire que cette émission de télévision au
départ et lorsque vous la l'enregistrer
n'est qu'un jeu radiophonique pour un
peu oui pour le pour les candidats et
pour moi-même ça se passe exactement
comme un jeu radié pour philippe de
dieuleveult de la même façon d'ailleurs
puisque nous nous travaillons lui avec
le casque sur les oreilles et moi avec
un retour soit un plateau comme dans les
studios de radio et nous nous
rendons plus ou moins bien d'ailleurs
c'est un autre problème parce que c'est
souvent très très loin et je me souviens
de certaines émissions en afrique du sud
ou bien aux américains ou les liaisons
étaient assez difficiles lorsque en plus
il ya des problèmes de décalage horaire
et vraiment on ne voit donc rien puisque
techniquement ça serait pratiquement
impossible tout cas ça coûterait des
milliards c'est pas du tout le but de
l'opération
donc impossible de voir l'image en même
temps donc nous nous sommes les seuls à
n'avoir que la liaison son et un son qui
n'est pas toujours fameux si bien que la
moitié de mon travail a consisté à
essayer d'écouter et de traduire et
notamment pour les non seulement pour
les téléspectateurs
mais surtout pour les concurrents qui
sont dans les mêmes conditions coin et
qui en plus ont le gros désavantage est
obligé de lire de rechercher de penser
et ça paraît idiot à dire comme ça mais
c'est très difficile de d'écouter
quelque chose de difficile d'entendre et
de lire et dessus sa propre pensée dans
un sens vous êtes surtout
l'intermédiaire entre dieu le veut et
les candidats alors que vous jouez vous
avez le droit de jouer au cours de cette
cette émission je le droit de jouer dans
la mesure où je ne vois rien je suis
donc exactement la même condition que
les gelées
le couple qui joue mais en plus je peux
jouer parce que je ne sais rien non plus
je ne sais je ne connais rien de lénine
ne se serait pas drôle si je connais
c'est l'énigme et je crois que je
pourrais même pas faire l'émission à ce
moment là parce que j'ai je pourrais pas
qu'à l'émission si je connaissais
l'énigme parce que je pourrai pas les
aider du tout donc je serai un simple
relais mécanique
je serai très gêné j'aurais peur de les
conduire dans un mauvais dans une
mauvaise direction
alors que l' avantage de ne rien savoir
c'est qu'effectivement ça donne envie de
jouer et de gagner avec eux de les voir
gagner
quels sont les impératifs de cette
émission vous ne faites pas à 1 heure
fixe je croise assez doit être un
problème tout de même vous et de rage et
de l'enregistrer au moment où il fait ça
je crois que c'est un autre problème je
sais que jacques a déjà beaucoup répondu
la team je crois qu'on peut leur dire
une fois de plus dit que c'est une
émission qui est diffusée en différé
mais qui s'enregistrent vraiment dans
les conditions du direct
ensuite on ne fait que mélanger les
images tournées de deux côtés c'est sur
le plateau à paris et avec philippe de
dieuleveult et son équipe sur le terrain
donc on va mélanger ensuite c'est le
seul travail c'est à dire qu'on mélange
deux images mais dans la durée
et elle a été enregistrée en une heure
ça se retourne exactement comme une
émission de direct
et alors le résultat c'est
qu'effectivement avec le décalage
horaire et bien quand on s'en va en
arizona on a neuf heures de décalage
donc les gens vont nous voir à 17 ou 18
heures le
dimanche mais en fait on a très bien pu
enregistrer à 23 heures le soir parce
que ça correspondait à la meilleure
heure pour le soleil et pour l'équipe
mais mes camarades vous expliqueront
dans quelles conditions ils déterminent
la bonne heure de tournage est cependant
en a fait d'autres plus on s'en va vers
l'est et qui ont tourné tôt le matin
c'est dans l'autre sens les autres
impératif que vous avez vous êtes quand
même un petit peu tenu d'attendre que
tout se passe bien tactiquement sur le
lieux extérieurs à l'étranger les vraies
difficultés mais là encore c'est pas mon
problème à moi c'est pas mon problème
animateur c'est le problème de toute
l'équipe les voies et c'est bien pire
pour les producteurs d'ailleurs jacques
qui est à côté
man show man plus de crayons en bois que
moi j'ai du souci les toits parce qu il
nous est arrivé quand même de d'avoir la
liaison cinq minutes avant l'émission ça
se passait à l'autre bout du monde
et puis d'avoir une rupture de liaison
téléphonique était un simple petit pépin
téléphonique
mais il faut six heures pour le réparer
or six heures quand ils sont en place
soleil par 40° et au zimbabwe c'est une
catastrophe
de notre côté nous on peut attendre six
ans pour faire c'est très agréable vous
vers les césars des angoisses du
producteur mais vos concurrents ils
doivent quand même c'est un métier de
jouer presque pour la télé mais c'est un
jeu quand même et je crois que tous les
concurrents nous avons vu jusqu'ici joué
vraiment or certains sont un petit choc
nerveux
or on a vu une dame effectivement qui a
failli fait son mari pendant toute
l'émission parce que ça se voyait
pratiquement elle prétendait que c'était
de sa faute si elle allait perdre
elle a fini par perdre d'ailleurs et
et on a vu une autre qui s'est effondré
à la fin d'émission on a vu des hommes
qui étaient incapables de parler
effectivement pendant l'émission mais ça
c'est l' angoisse du jeu c'est vrai je
crois pour tous je sais c'est pas le
sait pas le plus dramatique je pense le
plus difficile effectivement celle
angoisses de l'équipe qui réalise et qui
à établir à chaque fois cette
performance assez incroyable au fait qui
m'étonne moi toujours c'est que déjà on
sait bien qu'en télévision radio on peut
avoir des pépins sur un kilomètre de
distance mais quand ça se fait par de
tels relais par un simple téléphone et à
six sept ou huit mois j'admire beaucoup
les i c'est aussi l'équipe il ya qui
réalise à chaque fois et le producteur
qui a eu l'idée un peu dingue à mon avis
de de tenter ce pari à chaque émission
parce que cela c'est un pari qu'on peut
voir à chaque fois mais c'est quand même
une idée superbe allait super bien et
comme allant là comme joueur puisque je
suis autant jouer en qu'animateur sur sa
formidable fils de dieu le veut vous
êtes celui qui est ailleurs qui est à
l'étranger et qui donne aussi beaucoup
et qui joue aussi beaucoup parce que je
le précise encore il ya très peu de
jours et je les présenterai tout à
l'heure qui sont au courant de l'énigme
vous vous partez là bas vous ne savez
rien comme lorsque je monte dans les
commentaires c'est pour aller se mettre
en place pour la première image jean
falala obligé en place qu'est ce que ça
veut dire je pense que les producteurs
choisissent à un paysage qui soit quand
même assez agréable oui à voir parce
qu'au début d'émission savait que les
candidats cherchent dans les bouquins
qui sont un petit peu perdues donc dans
ce cas là on a en démarrant déjà une
très belle image du d'hélicoptères
derniers mois je vais vendre un
hélicoptère et puis je découvre
complètement des glycols table 10
allaient à tel endroit j'y vais avec le
plus grand plaisir parce que maintenant
en plus dans l'achat écoutez vous êtes
bien écouter ce que vous demande le
filet oui alors y aller le plus vite
alors bien écoutez c'est également un
gros problème parce que les liaisons ne
sont pas toujours très bonnes c'est vrai
et en plus de ça j'ai le bruit de
l'hélicoptère qui est quand même assez
infernal s'était occupé du pilote de la
carte éventuellement dudit boussole de
vérifier c'est le caméraman suis bien
derrière si la casse était bien dans les
dents métaux fins de ce que bien sûr
dans le mato scop s'il n'y est pas il
faudra à son la coupe et un petit paris
s'est interrompue fille vouliez dire
quelque chose s'est elle est là oui non
je voulais dire que les débuts les
premières émissions étaient disons un
petit peu pour tout le monde une grande
aventure
la tendance est toujours grande aventure
mais c'est une ambiance dans
l'hélicoptère qui est fantastique parce
que jean yves le maner vous le disiez je
viens quand on est à l'heure est
formidable mais il
- bruno delattre par francis ciment et
thierry pouch on va les voir tout à
l'heure quand on a un petit film sur un
nouveau tournage
en fait je vais vous demander ce que
vous vous êtes vous êtes angoissé
inquiet serein tranquille parce que tout
de même présenter ou plutôt courir ce
tout au long de la session ça va très
vite je ne suis pas angoissé parce que
c'est pas compliqué ce qu'on me demande
on demande d'obéir donc je sais pas si
c'est vrai je vais je montre dans
l'hélicoptère aller à tel endroit je
regarde la carte ok ça me semble évident
moi je serais pour les ans des noms ici
n'était pas sourd ça sera pire mais il
est souvent souvent est ce que quelqu'un
vous avez eu peur parce que tout de même
dans des endroits où on vous attend pas
toujours on vous fait faire tout de même
des balades dans des dents des dans des
lieux un petit peu impressionnant je
pense que mon caractère est fait pour ce
jeu moi je m'amuse je m'amuse beaucoup
et j'ai envie d'aller justement là où je
ne sais pas ce qui va se passer
tout à l'heure vous êtes un ancien la
course autour du monde sait cela et qui
a été repêché dans cette émission vous
étiez déjà au journal sur antenne 2 puis
je travaille comme journaliste d'image
depuis trois ans il ya maintenant je
voudrais demander aux assistants et qui
ont un rôle très important sur cette
émission de me dire un petit peu comment
ça se passe d'abord la question qu'on se
pose toujours c'est nous quand on est
devant attersee dans notre récepteur
tout est fait à quel moment
commencez-vous à travailler sur une
émission
moi je te parle un peu plus que rené
parce qu'il est un peu et l'impact de
gorge de vous faites la même chose
will smith ferrand où il est c'est à
dire que rené s'occupe de l'équipe qui
travaille avec claude savary et que je
m'occupe de celles qui travaillaient que
jean-luc pasquier qui partira ensuite
sur le tournage
notre problème c'est de
d'aller sur place de repérer les lieux
où vont se dérouler les missions à
partir de lénine qui aura été préparé à
paris avec jacques antoine c'est donc
d'aller sur place et d'être chiffres que
tout va fonctionner que on pourra se
poser à tel endroit et que les lieux
correspondent bien aux textes préparés
c'est vous qui monte le jeu de piste sur
place en quelque sorte une préparation
du jeu de piste sur pouvoir vérifier que
tout ce qui a été imaginé par jacques
antoine est ce ça correspond bien à l
horizon l'image qu'on avait à paris
là vous faites donc avoir un premier
voyage bien avant l'émission bien avant
l'émission pour aller sur place avec
leurs fins les choses qu'on a réuni à
paris on a réglé dans les livres et
c'est toute une documentation mais ça
correspond rarement à ce qu'il ya sur
place il faut donc souvent arranger un
petit peu et puis revenir avec jacques
en reparler avec jacques hélias moment
là les autres sont prêts à partir est ce
que c'est à ce moment là que vous
déposez le trésor absolument déjà la
personne n'est venu le nom de par hasard
non c'est pas encore arrivées ont vogué
chaque fois pour que ça n'arrive pas
bien et vous faites la même chose mais
alors vas y que jean-luc avec donc je
fais équipe avec claude savary et donc
c'est en général jean il ne l'a pas dit
mais c'est un mois et demi deux mois
avant que les émissions ne se réalise
vraiment qu'il faut donc aller dans le
pays pour vérifier que j'aurais vous
préciser tous les deux le jour de
l'enregistrement de l'émission dont vous
vous êtes occupés vous n'êtes jamais
là-bas vous êtes madame à paris nous
sommes avant tout un ami de jacques
antoine sur le sur le studio avec donc
cesser les candidats philippe futa alors
que vous deux les réalisateurs au
contraire vous partez avec l'équipe qui
est à l'extérieur à l'étranger alors que
de savoir que j'aimerais d'abord que
vous m'expliquer ce que cela représente
comme organisation comme travail pour un
réalisateur d'être sur le point
extérieur par rapport aux studios
d'abord je sais que vous avez préparé
dans un week end un petit déçu oui je
dis vous nous crier pour qu'enfin on
comprennent clairement je vais préparer
un petit dessin parce qu'il pleut on dit
souvent qu'un petit croquis vaut mieux
que les grands discours pour vous
expliquer justement réponse en effet si
on commence à fonctionner et ce que je
vais faire sur place avec l'équipe
technique
si vous voulez symbolisée ici de ce côté
ci du dessin nous avons paris le sud de
paris avec philippe et les deux
candidats et
sur ce côté ci de l'image j'ai marqué
l'australie pour bien marquer que nous
sommes loin et vous savez convaincre et
loin qu'on va l'autre bout du monde et
là il ya l'équipe extérieur symbolisée
par évidemment l'hélicoptère et philippe
de dieuleveult
alors si dieu le veut vous l'avez
peut-être déjà remarqué dans les
émissions il a une espèce de pot au noir
il a une petite boîte noire sur la
poitrine avec une antenne c'est un
émetteur récepteur de radio
lorsqu'il parle dans son micro c'était
bête au récepteur envoie sa voix dans un
relais radio qui se trouve dans un petit
avion léger qui vole au dessus de lui
qui fait des ronds au dessus de lui
parce qu'en plus de l'hélicoptère bien
l'avion qui est un relais un relais
radio sonore de cet avion la voix de
philippe va partir vers un point haut ce
que nous appelons notre station de
basket une une grande antenne que nous
installons sur le lieu l'émission disons
dans un point élevé pour obtenir la
meilleure liaison possible au point de
vue radio et à cet endroit là au pied de
cette antenne
eh bien nous avons un téléphone tout
bêtement un téléphone et ce téléphone
il est relié au studio à paris et c'est
à la grande salle à la grande astuce
c'est qui ce passe un jeu au téléphone
au téléphone bien entendu philippe de
dieuleveult ne sait pas trop ce qui se
passe à paris si ce n'est que parce que
vigile gildas est en revanche philippe
gildas ne voit rien il ne sait que j'ai
huit départs contre rapide lorsque cette
voie qui est passé par son petit
émetteur l'avion la station relais de
base et la ligne téléphonique alors elle
qui peut nous ramener depuis l'australie
par exemple sur ce dessin jusqu'au sud
de boulogne est bien là arrivent ici
dans un run en haut parleurs et philippe
gildas et ses deux concurrents entendre
fort bien par ce haut parleur
c'est vrai que le renouveler de tout
c'est vrai que j'aurais dû ajouter tout
à l'heure que le l'une des grandes
difficultés
effectivement c'est que lui d'une part
ne voit pas d'un même pas idée de la
tête qu'on les concurrents et il va
découvrir les concurrents
le jour où l'émission est diffusée sur
un thème que c'était à moi qu'elle ait
tourné ou deux semaines trois mois après
mes îles des kouriles et voire même par
les téléspectateurs et nous en plateau
tire les candidats vont voir les images
en même temps que moi à la télévision
par 10 0 gagnent ou perdent mais nous
n'avons rien vu avant absolument rien du
tout avoir et comment vous rendez vous
sur les lieux du jeu je vais vous
surprendre on y va en avion au niveau en
avion mais avec un avion un peu
particulier parce que nous louons un
petit jet
ça semble un peu onéreux d'état mais en
fait les cons sont bien fait c'est comme
la chose là là
du tas moins onéreuse pour transporter à
la fois tout ce matériel que vous voyez
sur l'image maintenant ces stations
relais de radio la station de base radio
car si le matériel est roi qui m'ont les
gens ce n'est celle de cameramen et
l'homme du magnétoscope et le petit
relais radio de philippe de dieuleveult
la station de base elle est le relais
radio qui sera dans le petit avion qui
va survoler l'ensemble de l'émission
c'est quand même beaucoup de matériel
c'est pratiquement 700 kg de matériel
alors nous embarquons tout ce matériel
et l'équipe technique dans ce petit
learjet vous le voyez il est 5 heures du
matin au projet on va partir et toute
cette équipe par pour un pays lointain
qu'en général elles n'a jamais découvrir
ou connus avant et elle ne sait
absolument pas ce que sera li ning ce
que sera le présent à chercher aux parts
dans la nuit en plein brouillard pour le
bout du monde
évidemment on disait tout à l'heure il
manque un certain nombre de vos
collaborateurs sur ses missions ce sont
ces fameux homme de l'équipe technique
qui est sur place à l'étranger alors
vous avez très gentiment à porter un
film où vous nous les présenter les uns
les autres j'aimerais qu'on les voit
maintenant oui c'est un film qui a été
fait par nos amis de l'audio fine la
télévision suisse et qui nous avait
filmé un jour voilà pour la chasse au
trésor alors c'est peut-être je crois le
moment de vous montrer à la fois ceux
qui sont devant la caméra et derrière la
caméra ce que vous ne voyez pas alors il
y a tout d'abord bien entendu le pilote
d'hélicoptère le pilote d'hélicoptère
c'est jojo projet qui est suisse puisque
nous sommes à nation et qui avec son
hélicoptère va nous emmener partout les
candidats le demanderont merci jo nous
avons évidemment philippe de dieuleveult
le reporter lui vous le connaissez bien
vous le voyez à toutes les émissions
il est l'homme qui court l'homme qui
cherche ses trésors pour les candidats
mais avec lui il y a deux garçons très
important c'est ce qu'il faut l'image ya
jean yves jean yves le maner que vous
voyez d'habitude au début de mission que
je vous présente avec sa caméra et nous
avons patrick simon patrick simon qui
lui est en charge de tout ce qui est le
francis immo qui est en charge de du de
tout ce qui vit d eau du bain de ska
partie de vous que lorsque vous voyez
philippe courir eh bien il ya derrière
jean yves et francis qui courent eux
aussi derrière et ils sont ils sont en
plus chargées de cette caméra et de sa
bêta scop alors eux aussi l'esprit
sportif pour eux n'est pas une petite
affaire
et lorsque nous avons fini avec l'image
est bien il ya maintenant le problème du
sur le problème du son c'est la liaison
entre l'hélicoptère à philippe de
dieuleveult partout où ils se trouvent
et le sio de paris avec les candidats et
fils
gildas et bien cette théorie est assurée
par patrick qui lui assure tout ce qui
est liaison radio avec une station de
base qui se trouve là aujourd'hui à
savièse au dessus de la au dessus de la
région de sion et entre l'hélicoptère et
la station de savièse kiss à qui elle
est liée à paris par une liaison
téléphonique normal
nous avons un avion un avion relais pour
permettre que la liaison surface
toujours bien entre l'hélicoptère et
c'est cette station de savièse et dans
cet avion qui est piloté par petter
théorie suisse comme le pilote
d'hélicoptère dans la voip terre il via
une station radio graulhet voilà tout le
système tel qu'il se présente c'est un
système assez lourd mais fiable et qui
nous permet chaque semaine doit être
dans un pays différent tout autour du
monde pour faire cette chasse aux
trésors jour n'a d'ailleurs en suisse
nos amis de télévision suisse avait un
deuxième hélicoptère et ils ont filmé
notre hélicoptère pendant toute
l'émission ils nous ont littéralement
suivi comme des chiens de chasse pendant
les 45 minutes du jeu à sion alors vous
voyez l'hélicoptère et sur son aire de
départ prêt à partir avec philippe le
pilote et le cameraman les jean yves le
maner et francis simon monumenta scop
ils sont partis ils montent à près de
promenade altitude voyez ce petit point
blanc qui monte au dessus du barrage
c'est l'hélicoptère il franchi le
barrage de la grande dixence est
maintenant sur les ordres des candidats
il se rend vers un autre lieu qui je
crois va être le château de valère dans
la vallée au pied de ce magnifique
massif des alpes alors envoyé la caméra
de la caméra de
jean yves le maner kiss him en
permanence car la caméra n'arrête pas de
tourner n'arrête pas de filmer pendant
toute la durée du jeu et on arrive à
proximité du château de valère où les
candidats ont demandé à philippe de
dieuleveult d'atterrir pour essayer de
quémander d'avoir quelques
renseignements sur l'histoire de la
région pour essayer de grosses trouve le
trésor l'hélicoptère est posée là
l'image est très intéressante parce que
vous voyez
philippe est sorti il court il court
dans la neige mais il n'est pas seul ils
sont trois derrière lui il ya eu jean
yves le maner l'est